- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
And I just wanted to give a
huge shout out and thank you
to Elon Musk and everyone
at the Musk Foundation
for their incredibly generous
support for Khan Academy,
they just recently gave
a $5 million donation
to Khan Academy.
Elon I hope you really
feel good about this.
This is going to allow us
to accelerate all sorts of content.
Our aspirations are all subjects
from K through the
early stages of college.
This will accelerate our science content,
allow us to do more on early learning,
allow us to make the
software and the practice
that much more engaging
for millions of students
around the world, for
teachers around the world.
And as far as Khan Academy has come,
we have 120 million registered users,
20 or 30 million students
using the platform every month.
We have about 200 million
hours of learning a year,
which any way you want to evaluate that
that's worth a lot to the world.
And when you look at our efficacy studies
and how we've been able to
move the dial in classrooms
just that social return
to investment ratio
is 400 to 500 to one.
A good return in the philanthropic sector
is considered a five to one
ratio or 10 to one ratio.
So as much as progress has been made,
I think you appreciate,
and hopefully everyone
watching appreciates
that there's many billions who need this
there's people throughout the planet
who need a way to tap
into their potential.
And I view this type of
investment in what we're doing
as really foundational
for us to be able to build
a multi-generational institution.
So that future Elon Musk's of the world
are also able to tap into their potential
and help all of us up-level
who we are as a civilization,
for everyone listening
I wanna remind folks
that as incredible as this donation is,
and it really is incredible,
that we do need more help
we continue to be running
at a deficit for 2021.
So every donation of every size helps
and we're able to take
every one of those dollars
and it helps us accelerate learning
in a whole bunch of dimensions.
The world as a whole spends $5 trillion
on education annually
Khan Academy's budget
is one, 100,000th of that.
We are the budget of a large high school,
but our aspirations
are to serve the globe.
So hopefully, more folks
listening at all scales,
can help support what we're trying to do.
And the last thing I'll mention,
and it's especially powerful to get
a donation from you Elon.
I had the privilege of
interviewing you back in 2013,
when you visited our office
and someone on YouTube commented.
I wanna find someone who looks at me
the same way that Sal looks at Elon
and they were catching onto something.
I do look up to you and incredible way
any time that I questioned even myself
and I say, is this mission too big
to actually try to
educate all of humanity?
I think of the incredible
work that you've done.
I remember back in 2013
when I interviewed you
pretty much everything you
said you were going to do,
and you made some pretty large statements
you have either done or your
very close to doing right now.
And I take incredible inspiration
that it is not too big of a mission
that if anything, we
cannot shy away right now
from this goal,
just as we shouldn't shy
away from solving climate,
solving transportation,
being able to colonize other planets,
we can't shy away from
educating the planet
and other planets, going forward.
So thank you so much and I look forward
to going on this journey
with all of y'all.